but let's do this let's talk about the
next wave of cancel culture oh let's do
it this story is probably one of the
craziest stories I have ever seen yeah
and they've walked it back already check
this out NBC News says Google band's
website Zero Hedge from its ad platform
over comments on protest articles a
Google spokesperson said in an e-mail
that it took action after determining
the website violated its policies on
content related to race when they
initially reported this they also added
the Federalist was banned and they admit
that the reporter claimed that they were
working in tandem with an activist
organization I believe a uk-based
activist organization and another
us-based activist organization
contacting Google with a list of
websites that they want banned and
Google said yes Wow
yes so Tim who's our competition we
should write a letter that's a good idea
router steven crowder google hey google
proud of your awesome no they already
won have to all right
that's that's the game right no who's
the limousine to our taxi cab company
right the murray hill right right it's
like now I'm not super concerned I guess
it's technically NBC so should we start
a non-profit charity organization called
like you know ending hate and sending
love and then we'll target anything that
NBC ever does we're like mmm they're so
bigoted yeah Google are you really gonna
search and you know Index this that
people can find this and then one by one
not actually think it's a good idea but
NBC is doing this and they actually say
that there's like a list of 10 websites
let me see if it's a hit list
yup their hit list they changed the
article because they were wrong what's
interesting though is they changed it
from two websites to just Zero Hedge and
the other thing is they were claiming
victory like we teamed up and we did it
Yahoo it's like actually Google Google
says they banned Zero Hedge just last
week Wow oh yeah Wow yeah so so NBC no
sorry particular side they say Google
also issued a warning
on Tuesday to the federalists over
comments on articles related to recent
posts wait a minute comment doesn't
Google like section 230 Google wants to
hold a website responsible for the
content of other people
well amazing isn't it how we heard
utterly disgusting Google I'm so sick of
this yeah Google Google will go to a
hearing where the like under section 230
protections we can't be held responsible
for the content posted by other people
but everyone else and then they look
over and say now the content imposed by
other people on your website well for us
that's fair game you know because we're
in charge
uh-huh well now Donald Trump jr. tweeted
like response to this story cuz freaked
everybody out yeah dude I should I think
Google did ban the Federalists I think
they did I think so too
so the initial report said that Google
confirmed they banned the Federalists
and there's even a statement look at
this we have strict publisher policies
that govern the content at the content
ads can run on and explicitly prohibit
derogatory content that promotes hatred
intolerance violence or discrimination
based on race from monetizing when a
page or site violates our policies we
take action in this case we've removed
both sites ability to monetize Wow
a minute so it's the but NBC says just
Zero Hedge they say they just issued a
warning wait wait
didn't they tweet out didn't Google
tweet out we did not deem monetize yep
but it says it right there they did
exactly so is NBC lying
I don't lose lying I want an answer both
lying yeah I don't know listen I don't
think NBC would make up this email
because that's libelous
yeah and they could easily be targeted
by Google here's what I think when this
story broke I immediately tweeted it out
NBC News contacted Google to target
their competition to get them banned and
Google said yes
thousands of retweets very very quickly
this story exploded so many people were
blasting it out then all of a sudden
like an hour later Google goes no we are
we didn't bet anybody what do you mean
this is a clearly a misunderstanding I
think I have the tweet here yes the
federal suite was what's different -
monetized we know what I was talking
about yeah we worked with them to
address issue
on their site related to the comments
section our policies do not allow ads to
run against dangerous or Kotori content
which includes comments on sites what
cake and eat it too
I say lazy exactly that's the Google
you're nasty and we offer guidance and
best practices to publishers on how to
comply as the comments section has now
been removed we consider this matter
resolved and no action will be taken
I am sad to see that the Federalists had
to remove their comment section but I
got to be honest I don't care for
comment sections anyway I think yeah and
there's other ways the Federalists can
resolve this but I still think it's
complete BS the Federalists should not
have had to remove their comment section
because they're protected under section
230 but Google doesn't care now I'm tell
you what I think happened Oh Google
Google thinks they're above it yeah and
there's a difference they got the power
care they care if it does affect them
but they are above it and they don't
well so we're not even affected by this
in in that line of thinking here's what
I think happened I think Google was like
oh we're getting hit up by NBC better
banned them and did and they said they
did you know NBC but then all of a
sudden a trend emerged on Twitter
showing that this was one of the biggest
mistakes Google made in terms of banning
some kind of platform yeah and then they
realized we're gonna lose more money yep
quick quick go back way too far they
flicked a domino down the first one and
it's like that's what we're talking
about the magic Wizards of the coast
earlier yeah they banned a bunch of
cards that didn't make any sense just
because it revolved around a color of
identity of a creature that there's five
colors in magic so one of those is white
now if you're white you're racist sounds
like wait okay so you're adding racism
into the game by doing that so Google is
basically shooting yourself in the foot
here well it's worse than that you know
I got worse way worse I think some dumb
really dumb like content moderator
person okay gets the email and they go
oh oh oh bleep photorealist deleted we
deleted them and then the lawyers for
Google got wind of it when the story
broke and they went here a liar dear God
the FTC is going to drop a hammer on us
yes and we are now going to be regulated
welcome to the club Google
there is nothing you can do it this like
you know what I got to be honest I'd
like to say that Google will now be
regulated to some extreme degree or even
broken up I don't believe it because I
think I think the GOP is particularly
ineffective so they're not gonna do
anything I mean look what they did with
two years of controlling every branch of
government or on the house the house in
the Senate i should say specifically
nothing nothing they wasted I mean to be
fair you had you know what Paul Ryan and
who else was still very much of um
retired because they're relaxed so maybe
they're doing better now to be fair I'm
not confident gonna do anything yeah III
do think people like like like Trump jr.
and you know III know Trump jr. is
particularly active and all the stuff
he's set up on it yeah yeah and he's
done stuff with like Dave Rubin about
this kind of stuff
so I think he's paying attention and he
just tweeted out in response to this
it's time to haul them into you know
subpoena them I get the CEO because
they're out of control
yes here I think they banned the
Federalists and then when the lawyer
found out they're probably likely
quickly yeah back they can be an idiot a
huge meeting probably got convened and
they were like oh who did it who did it
you're fired you're out so fired
I'm sure no I'm about getting fired
because it was the policy it was a
matter of time before they they went too
far he was crazy is like I'm worried
about getting banned the Federalist is
conservative yeah and they've banned and
and News guard gives a negative rating
to the Federalists mm-hmm but it's still
extremely high-profile you like you've
got Sean Davis and you got Molly
Hemingway very very high profile
conservative personalities and molly is
like yes seriously talented yeah like
some conservatives have praised her as
being like one of the best writers and
she's appeared on Fox News so this is
like Google went way over the over the
red line yeah and now I think you might
start seeing Republicans be like oh you
mean we're actually in trouble you see
you see the GOP didn't really do much
when it was Paula Joseph Watson or Miley
innopolis okay or Laura luma it was like
all these people got banned well I'll
give them a stern talking-to but now
they're coming for the Federalists now
you're probably gonna see some of these
more mainstream Republicans start
sweating bullets like oh whoa whoa are
they really actually do something yeah
or not that that's like am I gonna get
real
acted because is Google only going to
allow far-left propaganda get monetized
and conservative point of view will just
be erased yeah maybe they're now
realizing what's really gonna get out
earlier yeah maybe maybe from the people
that watch mainstream media yep yeah
dude it's ridiculous well now what's the
percentage of people you think that
actually watch mainstream media though
it's a lot just curious what do you
think was its 80% 80% of Americans who
think well yeah media not to what degree
is the bigger question okay I think most
Americans probably passively will have
liked the news playing from some you
know standard Network outlet and they're
gonna get fed some trash news and I
think it's one of the reasons why
Sinclair has been buying up a lot of
local news station Sinclair is
considered to be more conservative okay
because they know that the average
person is just watching fox or ABC or
CBS or something okay
liberals get 95 cent of their news from
left-wing outlets and mainstream outlets
moderates 60% mainstream Left 30%
conservative and conservatives is
inverted 60% conservative 30% liberal
mainstream then there's like you know
breakdown to some other you know the
remaining 10% and that makes sense
moderates and conservatives get along a
lot of issues disagree on some issues
and they get their news from slightly
different places but understand each
other okay the left doesn't know at all
what's going on at all
like I'll tell you what men might might
activist II friends who are like super
into black lives matter are still
posting to this day that a man fell
asleep in Wendy's parking lot and then
was shot and killed by a cop Wow and I'm
like nothing about his DUI you love her
that's a part of her second DUI well
hold on you left out the part where he
was in the drive-through lane with his
car running drunk right yes I'm leaving
right passed out drunk I want to call it
sleeping you know yeah good point and
and then you also left at the part where
he has a violent history and they're
called for backup and he was out on
parole he beaten two cops in a fight
yeah when they tried to restrain him he
did stoles weapon yep stole the weapon
yeah ran turned around and fired it at
the cop and then only after all of these
things right did the cop respond right
so that's that's because they don't
actually read the news no they don't
care to but as I said earlier the
narrative must fit their narrative or
else and they'll they'll carve and
take the whole story and pick
cherry-pick all the things put it
together in a nice little package yeah
did you hear about it around yeah hear
about Fox News in the Photoshop scandal
what with the it was the guy pulls a gun
on the chat there was a photo of the
Chazz and they photoshopped one of the
John Brown Gun Club guys I guess no I
didn't hear about those now so Fox used
a thumbnail for some articles okay that
showed one of the guys with guns at John
at the Chazz the Chop in front of like a
bar a building that was destroyed it was
very clearly in my opinion not a direct
representation of what was going on it
was just like a thumbnail graphic that
many news outlets often do okay where
they make what they call a collage now
this one was very like borderline in my
opinion like from far away if you
scrolled through it might look like
there was an armed guy standing front of
a destroyed building but I would say
every single news outlet has a graphics
department and they do similar things
but I think Fox News got you know they
were either just at the line slightly
over it or whatever so there was some
you know something to call that but I
talked to some people and they're like
that proves Fox News is completely fake
and I'm like it's one it's one thing
it's like one thing they happened one
time from one person right it was like
1:1 so like we can talk about the things
Fox has got wrong they have right we can
talk about New York Times CNN MSNBC
MSNBC if you want talk about getting
some wrong let's talk about MSNBC oh
yeah but they don't want to talk about
it they're like well I'm talking about
Fox and News right now and I'm like yep
Fox News gets things wrong it happens
you know are you satisfied no you still
want you still wanna act like Fox News
is the worst of the worst they're not
MSNBC is way worse and and Fox actually
I'm sorry I'm ascent BC it's not news
I'm just so sick of this blame game
that's what everyone does it's just it's
this person's fault it's this person's
fault I don't have any ideas I don't I
don't want to actually work towards
anything I just want to blame ya the
blame game easier frustrate what check
us out I want to highlight this right
here the NBC says Google's ban comes
after the company was notified of
research conducted by the Center for
countering digital hate a British
nonprofit that combats online hate and
misinformation
they found that 10 us-based websites
have published what they say are racist
articles about the protests
and project a and projected the websites
would make millions of dollars through
Google Ads the NBC reporter who wrote
this claimed they worked together overt
activism Wow / worked with with Google
know worked with the activists to label
to target so what they did was they
claimed initially and I believe this is
true that because of two articles the
Federalists were out claiming the media
had lied about what was going on with
black lives matter protests they
submitted those articles to Google and
then Google said they banned the
Federalists now Google's trying to walk
it back maybe it's a good thing that
Google is walking it back maybe it's a
good thing maybe it shows that there's
there is a hard line it could be a bad
thing maybe it shows that Google has no
like they have all they have a line that
they're willing to cross but they went
too fast and maybe they'll just keep
doing it it looks more like Google like
a chunk of their arm or fell off and
they're scrambling to put it back on
it's not like they're walking back
I mean sure technically speaking they
are but it feels like they are like whoa
whoa this is a threat to our superiority
in in the media realm it's fast let's
let's talk about one of the better
responses from Mike Serna vich okay he
responded directly to their tweet and
joy being regulated because it's going
to happen GOP is too weak but Democrats
will take up the action and Google won't
have a friend in the world yep Elizabeth
Warren wanted to do it you know it's
really funny Mark Zuckerberg and a lot
of these big tech companies we're like
we must take a hard stance on hate
speech and then all of a sudden
Elizabeth Warren and some Democrats come
out and they're like we're gonna break
up Google and Facebook and and regulate
and then all sudden Mark Zuckerberg
comes out with a PSA I have it all I've
had time to think about it free speeches
is paramount and very important and what
he was really doing was like I'm really
hoping the Republicans win because the
Democrats are gonna break up my company
and so please someone help Donald Trump
win and then now they started defending
free speech even after they already
banned a ton of people but now they're
backtracking saying we're appalled by
Donald Trump statements they can't
figure out who's gonna win that's the
funny thing
they can't
who's they that the media no no
Zuckerberg
oh yeah Big Daddy yeah they're like oh
they're like their basket they're
leaning to the left because they're
convinced Trump will lose but then as
soon as the left said we're gonna
regulate you there wha God then they
went to the middle no how do we do what
do we do that's coming at the end is
near so uh this is funny um Google
actually hired some people specifically
to liaised with moderate and
conservative commentary channels
interesting yep yeah when was that last
year okay yeah yeah so I can't say too
much about it but I know they did and
that says to me I think they're worried
about Trump getting reelected and
they're worried about this and now I
think it might be too late man I'm not
convinced like I I agree with Mike with
with Serna Mitch that there are public
at the GOP is too weak they just don't
even know what the GOP is doing to be
honest yeah that's that's that's the
thing I talk about like when people are
like why always record on the Democrats
too I'm like what Republicans doing if
they're just literally not doing a thing
really doing nothing yeah it's like all
you have is the Conservatives being like
look at all these problems with the
Democrats and then you have to be fair
you have Rand Paul blocking things but
that's good that is that is taking
action Ted Cruz has called this out Matt
Gaetz
and Josh Hawley yeah but other than that
it's like nothing's really happened in
four years this stuff's been going on
since what 2013 2012 oh yeah
escalating getting worse and worse and
worse it's it's it's really incredible I
mean if you really want to talk about it
like real reform like nothing's really
changed in a lot longer time than that
twenty years thirty years like what
really has changed a lots changed in
terms of government yeah I mean like
glass-steagall repeal and the allowing
of banks to use savings for futures and
investment or whatever whatever they did
that supposedly contributed to the
financial collapse essentially using
people's money like I'm not gonna
pretend to be an expert on that stuff
but there have been a bunch of dramatic
changes Barack Obama changing the rule
on the definitions of words in health
care title nine reform flipping back and
forth coño stuff that's actually changed
okay Obama care for instance
so we've actually gone through a ton of
different changes we've gone backwards
you want something crazy Jenna the
involuntary mandate was what under Obama
Obama's health care a deal if you didn't
buy health insurance you had to pay a
percentage of your income in a fine at
the end of the year dividual mandate the
individual voluntary that doesn't sound
good
well that's basically yeah yeah the
individual mandate Trump got rid of it
Wow because I I mean it seems
unconstitutional we're seeing someone to
buy a private product yeah so not okay
and dude I'll tell you it's really it
was really scary so an individual I know
I'm trying to protect her privacy the
best my ability was panicking because
they didn't make enough money to pay for
health insurance okay but they made
enough money to where they were gonna be
fined for not having health insurance
right so they were like what do i do
what do i do it's like I'm gonna lose
I'm gonna lose a little bit of money but
I can't afford it what am i doing what
do i do stop voting blue they didn't
vote at all that's the thing one one day
woke up and they were like oh crap
it's gonna cost me through you know like
it's like it was like they were they
were concerned that it would cost him
like 3 400 bucks a month for insurance
and if they didn't pay it it was gonna
cost them like a hundred bucks in fines
so they had no choice but to pay the
extra fine and lose money so something
like that I'm probably the numbers wrong
but they were like I'm gonna lose all
this money than it here I don't have any
money to begin with I'm poor and I'm
like yeah that's the funny thing about
how this works you can be poor ish but
just not poor enough to where you
actually get hit by these things you
don't qualify for benefits you know
things like that and that's a really
real challenge for people man
hard-working people - yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you